[Music]
your pal ran into your old flame the
other day
who angie who you oh she's acting
different
how's what she acting's different i
don't think you want to know how she's
acting different
wait
now was she acting different like i
think she was acting different she was
acting different exactly like you think
she was acting different oh
cripes so she was acting different just
like he's acting different like somebody
who's gone traveling for the first time
and then come home
and is acting different
is there anything worse stillborn
puppies and nothing else
this might be the worst case i've ever
seen
so she's speaking with a bit of an
accent then derry she came home speaking
with a wee bit of an accent
then as it now not every statement ends
like it's a question and dary everything
she says is a [ __ ] question
she using words like cheeky and bugger
why you cheeky bugger then hi derry you
cheeky burger i haven't seen you in a
bloody minute have i
haven't i has she gone mad is she
knackered tonight why am i cause she's
saying things to you like
cheers ring me no she did not say ring
you
should all are mine are you bothered i'm
not bothered aren't you you know do you
don't i do we
flower so she watches tv on the telly
then yeah and her apartment is now
referred to as her flat yeah and instead
of waiting in line she's waiting in the
queue now yeah
she's waiting in the queue for the tube
now yeah she's waiting in the queue for
the pub now yeah
waiting in the queue at the pub for a
point then yeah
amen now has she done ibiza derry has
she done
a pizza boy beefer has she done
bartholone
yeah derry has she done ball for owner
arthur luna
has she done budapest had dairy has she
done shlonker
is she schlonken has she done melbourne
not melbourne because it's pronounced
melbourne
melbourne drawing and she only watches
foreign features now yeah it's like did
she stay off of beaten path or did she
go to where it's touristy right because
you don't want to go to where it's too
touristy chat look
all she's done is hostels and backpacks
and kiwis
the bbc it was like she photographed in
like a cage with flyers today a tiger in
it
i've written a bloody travel blog
haven't i the bbc3 and it's like does
she get a little schlog get little facts
if she's a little
fat in it it's like there is comedy and
then there is british comedy you [ __ ]
bellend
it's like them yanks so the canadian
flags up on their backpacks what when
they go backpacking because you know
everyone loves them canadians yeah
i've unrolled me cigarettes haven't i
pull your finger out of your ass